joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
from ESPN the worldwide leader in sports
one of their top reporters in the
National Football League in a longtime
colleague of mine from NFL Network back
in the day
Jeff Darlington how are you Jeff I'm
doing well thanks for calling and I
really greatly appreciate it
let's get let's just jump right into it
as we are 8 days from the new league
year officially opening you said about a
week ago you'd be shocked if Brady
returned to New England your take on
that subject now would be what changed
the same yeah yeah same I continue to
sort of maintain what I had said there
in terms of yes I would be very
surprised that if Tom goes back to New
England based on a number of
conversations that I've had one of the
things that I had mentioned in that
segment on get up when I said that I
would in fact be stunned which was not
much different than what I said
previously in terms of just it being
much more likely than not that he goes
elsewhere but what's interesting about
it is I recognized that all of us have a
tough time digesting that likelihood
including the people closest to Tom the
people around Tom you can wonder what
happens when he ends up in that office
with Bill Belichick and Belichick you
know should Belichick decide to do
whatever it takes to convince Tom to
stay what happens what does Tom do and
decide in that moment but based on the
conversations that I've had tom is the
one that is looking at free agency and
excited about it so yeah that's where we
stand right now that that's okay that's
the reason why you're you're placing
your if you will
well-sourced postulate postulation let's
put the earlier instead of saying bet on
Brady not being back or have you heard
essentially he's just done he's just
flat-out done as opposed to having
potential Wanderlust no I mean I think
that I don't want to shut the door
completely on it to say he's flat-out
done because like I said I mean
everybody wonders what happens when goes
in
but I know that he is very excited about
entering free agency that he is looking
at this beyond just I think one of the
things that people assume is that this
is strictly because he's just over Bill
Belichick when there's another side to
it another component and that is that
Tom Brady is looking toward free agency
has another adventure a way to
reinvigorate himself a way to sort of
face another challenge so it's not
merely about running away from something
as much as it is also about chasing
after something new and I think the when
you put those two things together you've
got a guy who is looking at
opportunities that exist out there and
saying yeah that's that's something that
I'd like to be a part of well I'm sure
you heard charlie weis go on I think it
was our friend Golic and Windows program
saying you know Tom told me to tell the
world he doesn't know so nobody else
knows what would you make of that one I
do believe the things I've said along
the way is that you know I believe that
Tom does not know what he's doing next
in terms of he's been throwing a very
wide net I mean he's been not simply
saying you know these are the Titans or
the patron or I go back to the Patriots
you see there are the Chargers or I go
back to the Patriots he is considering a
lot of different things but to the point
that nobody knows anything I would
probably disagree with that to a degree
I mad
I feel feel pretty comfortable with with
the things that I've said so far Jeff
Darlington from ESPN joining me here on
the Rich Eisen show so then now handicap
it for me then where do you think eight
days from now the chances of him going
to a different team and where so I think
the number of teams that are first of
all as of last week as of probably four
or five days ago I had spoken to two
executives with eight different teams
that were showing at least to varying
degrees of interest now to go down each
team and say what degree of interest I
don't know that that's the right thing
to do at this point but I would say that
there's a number of teams that would
sign him right now right now Penn to pay
and whether Tom then considers those
teams to be the team's of that that he's
willing to marry that becomes what I
think happens in the next week to answer
your question in terms of handicapping I
still think that I know the people are
saying that the Titans feel like they're
you know not the spot forum that they're
not as interested in him look until a
team comes out and says we're not
signing Tom Brady I'm keeping them in
the race as a team of interest the
Titans the Bucks are another team that I
do not think that we should dismiss and
of course from the beginning the
Chargers and the Raiders are two teams
that remain in the hunt as well so those
four teams I think are the most likely
but that doesn't mean that we should
completely take the 49ers off the board
again look silence is deafening we're
not hearing weeks or people anybody
saying that that Tom Brady is not coming
to the 49ers and and I'm not saying that
that's the way we decide whether they
also they're interested but it certainly
means that they haven't been clear that
they're not so I think that we should
continue to keep them on our radar as
well you know that there's five teams
right there that certainly we should be
still considering as potential any Fox
Tom Brady so let's just place the Niners
aside because to me that would be in my
mind the spot where Brady would want to
go the most if he does want to leave New
England for various person so let's
let's just put the pin in that for a
moment let's just say it is the Titans
raising their hands and the Bucks and
Bruce Arians
and Gruden and the Raiders and the
Chargers here in Los Angeles and Brady
looks and he goes okay I'll need to
uproot my family period we he's got to
uproot his family to all these four
places two of them are in mahomes is
division okay right one of them one of
them may or may not have to Erick Henry
I'm assuming they will keep him if I
signed some sort of friendly deal and
another one is in Tampa you know state
taxes that'll be nice that they don't
have to have I'm serious but but I mean
they're they were particularly far away
like that is not my shot as much as I
love the No
get no biscuit and how we could
potentially put a team together and man
do I love Evans and I see Godwin and I
saw what what they did last year with
Jameis I could definitely cut those
interceptions by 90% and let's go but
they're they they seem to be far away
don't you think that those four if those
are the four that raise our hand that
would make doing one more attractive in
your mind yes I don't think so
you know I I think when we do look at so
first of all you're right the Titans are
definitely more interesting in fact
through the group it is probably hard to
get past with Derrick Henry then without
him but if they do have Derrick Henry
they're a team that was got to the AFC
Championship game just by really a
terrible start to the season so hard to
call them anything but a contender ender
in 2020 especially with Tom Brady I'm so
the Bucks I actually look at that team
toward the end of the season and look at
what their defense was able to do I
think that they definitely we need to
make strides on the offensive line
especially if they sign breathing
they've got to change a little bit of
the way they play if they bring in Grady
because Bruce Arians generally will get
his quarterback killed
god bless the guy I adore him but you
know you got to protect brady better if
he's going to go there but otherwise
they do check off a lot of the boxes
that I think Brady would be looking for
even though I know people have a tough
time thinking that Brady would look at a
place like Tampa not exactly a place
just you know rich in history in terms
of the NFL but I don't know that that is
as important as maybe we project it to
be so so those two teams I think are
probably more attractive than we realize
and then the charger certainly being in
Los Angeles is something that is the
type of thing for me with the Chargers
that I continue to not be able to get
past is that they moved on from Phillip
Rivers in part because Anthony Lynn
wants a more mobile quarterback with
better escape ability and all those
things that maybe someone like juoh
brings to the table I can't I find
myself not being able to get past that
despite the fact that I continue to hear
that the Chargers are most certainly
interested in signing Brady's well the
reasons
the reason for that is Jeff for just
interject
let's sitting out here in Los Angeles
Jeff Darlington of ESPN joining me here
and then we can continue on is that in
over the last 24 48 hours it is possible
again this is and this is an opportunity
where Brady may come here to Los Angeles
and play football
that is a very apparent to all the Los
Angeles NFL fans here the conversation
is and here in Los Angeles about the
football scene is is that leaked logo
that the Rams might be putting on their
caps and all of their uniforms is that
what we're seeing online really the Los
Angeles Rams new logo like for real you
know like that has been the conversation
not like is Brady really coming here
that's why the Chargers need Tom Brady
in the worst chef so Anthony Lin may
want more mobile more mobility but at
the end of the day to use that phrase
men do the Chargers need Tom Brady with
that new stadium opening up this fall
and I guess you could make a little bit
of that same argument for the Raiders to
I mean honestly I don't know that Jon
Gruden looks at Tom Brady well he might
love him like who's changing their
terminology there because I don't see it
being John Burton and when we talk about
needing a coaches collaborative yes
curtain will be that guy is you know a
fun uncle Gruden for the first few weeks
but all of a sudden when reality hits
start saying well this is by often what
happens then but I could still see Mark
Davis on the other side of that saying
we got a new stadium in a new market and
I'll be damned if we're not going to
consider adding a guy who will inject
their level of energy to your point
about the Chargers right in in this
organization like we absolutely so then
let's get to the 49ers aspect of this
Jeff you know and and by the way you
make an interesting point in the fact
that the rumor has been out there for at
least a week plus where Deon on NFL
Network during our Sunday coverage of
the combine flat-out just threw it out
there that Brady to the 49ers and having
like an NBA sign and trade with
Garoppolo going to New England for a
sign to Tom Brady would be a win-win for
everybody
Brady gets to wear the uniform that he's
been always wanting to wear as a kid
his kids get to be near his parents in
his final days as a quarterback in the
NFL he can jet down the coast to take
care of 199 productions that he just
opened up a shingle out here and in Los
Angeles I mean and then this is a team
it's got it all from from Kittel we know
how he loves to throw to a tight end to
a running game to a coach that he
respects and Lynch on the front office
all of it I mean so there's so much that
makes sense how does that happen though
walk me through how this happens simple
I mean here's the problem I think the
49ers really would like to get something
for Jimmy Garoppolo if they were to
trade him and what they could get I
think remains an enormous questioning
lingering over this but that being said
they could cut Jimmy Garoppolo and it
only cost them really four million
dollars they're not tied to his contract
in a way that makes this a situation
that can't be accommodated
so really it's simple I mean if you
can't treat Jimmy and you want Tom you
cut Jimmy and you signed Tom now
obviously that simplicity becomes a
little more complex when you start to
think about okay Jimmy is very well
liked within the organization the locker
room loves him like what happens you
know to the chemistry that exists within
this organization if you do that right I
don't know that it's I don't know that
Kyle Shanahan looks at that and says we
can't get past it
but that that's where this all lives
like I don't think this is just about
Jed York or John Lynch I think this is
ultimately about Kyle Shanahan that's
the guy who who I believe will determine
whether he wants Tom Brady or Jimmy
Garoppolo and and that's what I guess we
have to wait the next week to find out
but by all means it's still on the table
we can't say it's not I'm sorry I mean
they've got a quarterback who just took
them to the Super Bowl and I'm not
saying that they have to answer to every
rumor that exists out there but but this
is one where Jimmy Garoppolo behind the
scenes has to be saying hey guys
Yeah right over here yes yeah like where
where is the full throated denial
where's that one you know and it's not
like a exactly a responsible way to go
about reporting well they haven't said
no I know that I know like a pretty big
one you know I know I know the room and
until until we find out and fortunately
we only have about 7 to 10 days so I
think discover some real important
things
so until then oh so then why why doesn't
the Dallas rumor go away where's that
coming from because it doesn't dak have
a 33 million dollar a year deal on the
table and at some point he's gonna have
to get franchise tag before Brady is
allowed to even be legally contacted by
Dallas I mean why why why are we hearing
that rumor Jeff or anything I don't for
a second think that Jerry Jones well if
it's nothing more than use that as
leverage to try to get a deal done but I
mean you can certainly walk into that
negotiation and say look I can sign calm
Brady for less money than I can find you
right now why shouldn't I - which attack
will certainly set a good luck with that
well you know in two years have fun but
but uh I think I would I would imagine
at this point that's more of why should
the tabloids deny something that could
help them potentially in leverage than
it is a potential reality but no doubt
again I mean we're still sitting here
wondering what's going to happen and we
haven't heard a lot of doors slam shut
at this point when it comes to Tom Brady
right not at all
have you heard anything a couple more
minutes left with Jeff Darlington heard
anything from the league about the
owners meeting coming up and Vegas I
know that the the league came out and
said that they're monitoring the
situation that everything's still going
on is planned that would have a large
gathering obviously in Vegas and then
later on this that's down the road a
little bit but later on this month and
owners meeting gathering any any
conversation about postponing it here I
was uh I was talking to at least source
this morning you said that
as of this morning they have not decided
to cancel it but they are definitely
having contingency discussions at this
point about the owners meetings so where
that heads we'll have to wait and see
but you know certainly assembling 32
billionaire's many of whom are in an
older demographic I can't imagine that
they're ultimately thrilled about the
idea of being thrust into a group of
what do you call us reporters yes I'm
certainly sure that this will be a
conversation that you know in all
seriousness I'm you know that's a
light-hearted joke but in all
seriousness I mean this is definitely
going to be a conversation that we have
I know they're having it about the
owners meetings and I can't imagine that
they'll avoid it completely when it
comes to the draft but for now based on
my conversation this morning no plans to
cancel the owners meetings but
discussions certainly about contingency
plans well I mean yeah there could be
some telecommuting that takes place we
could set all that stuff up if votes
have to happen I understand all the
other fanfare that that members of the
NFL community always enjoy getting
together and certainly the the media
buzz that comes from that is significant
but that that's something that as you're
saying is under consideration right now
we see that locker rooms across the
other sports leagues are being shut down
anybody other than essential players in
personnel right I could certainly see
something like this that is seemingly
non-essential despite its obvious
importance to League matters I could see
that you know not being something that
the NFL says really dies we're not going
to take a chance here so we'll have to
wait and see on that one for sure okay
last one for you give me a wild-card in
the Brady race that we're not talking
about give me somebody to keep an eye on
drop me at Darlington bomb the doors
basically what I'm saying what do you
got what dropped me a Darlington bomb
out the door I think this is where my
connection starts to go bad right I
would just look I don't know I I'm not
going to drop any kind of crazy bomb on
you right now but
say when it comes to the box don't
dismiss them based on the helmet that
they wear or the city that they play in
I don't think that that will have as
much to do with the ultimate decision
that people maybe anticipated having
okay you want to ask him a question
going out the door right now
yeah Darlington this has been a hot
topic on our show yeah
what's your berating oh my god I think
last I checked and I did check because
I'm incredibly vain
it was 4.83 salad that salad
what do you where does that like where
does that fit into the expectation oh no
that's great rich is a 4.5 4 that's why
we're asking all I know is that I'm not
a fan of the math whatever the formula
is I don't know I've never had an
argument I don't get into arguments I'm
always a very I'm not a door slammer I
leave I don't leave rappers behind I
don't leave anything if you're the type
when you asked to confirm settings if
you asked for no conversation I don't
I'm a no preference guy I don't care I
don't care guy I'm a tipper I'm a no
preference guy I don't make them wait I
don't but I don't talk very often I'm on
the phone a lot I am on a lot to talk
well that declines you because of the
4.5 rating they're missing out on my
passenger experience Thank You Jeff I
appreciate it thanks for the call we'll
chat soon you got it as a man who's on
top of it all as Jeff Darlington from
ESPN